and and i was moaning about it and my
husband in this typical manner he
said well instead of mourning why don't
you do something about it and i said
that's
it that's right i'm going to start an
indian condiment food business
and and i'm going to show the people of
england what really indian condiments
are about
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today we're talking to an
engineer turned food
entrepreneur her name is swati biwal
founder and director of the cheeky food
company
swati is a computer engineer and
mathematician by education
food entrepreneur by work and mother at
heart she finished a bachelor's in
computer science and a master's in
mathematics at one of the leading
universities in india
however three jobs four countries and
two children later
she realized that the corporate tech
world was not for her
with the 200 pound investment cheeky
food has now grown into a
well-established
british brand of premium indian
condiments
meet sualty swati vival welcome to 20
minute leaders
how are you yeah i'm very well thank you
michael how are you
i i am great thank you i'm really
excited for us to
be doing this show together and
generally i know the people when they go
study computer science and then
mathematics for their masters
and they end up doing you know all sorts
of different things
and they don't always go and sort of
food business
and so i'm excited to hear about your
interesting journey and how you even got
there
uh and so i i have to go back to you
studying in one of the leading
universities in india you're an engineer
by profession
what led you even to study computer
science and mathematics
you know what i'll just say it i'll just
put it out there as
silly as it sounds computers um computer
science was the leading
subject at the time i i did my
university when i um
in 1999 and that was it was
the world was moving into tech the world
is still moving into tech
um and it just seemed like um that would
be the way
forward uh and it is
uh it just wasn't for me so i i i
jumped in thinking well this is what you
know this is this is on trend
thinking analytically always came quite
easy to me i
always had signs always appealed to me
so
it just seemed like a natural
progression it was only when i
sort of i even enjoyed
learning computer science i even enjoyed
doing mathematics and i still enjoy
those aspects um but i just think that
the tech world that i worked in
um primarily from 2004 to 2008
just didn't appeal that much to me and
um i've been following some of the
recent uh latest uh developments in tech
and i
i wish like you know that is what was
happening when
when i was in the tech world because
that it certainly sounds um quite
interesting much more interesting than
what
i was doing for work interesting and so
as you're finding yourself in this
situation and you're
trying to understand what it is that you
want to be doing i imagine that it can't
be easy to take you know a life and a in
a career that you're building and saying
you know what
this is not for me it must be a really
scary thing to do
i i i don't remember it being scary as
such
i i think i just remember
um i remember six months into my first
job telling one of my colleagues
i said i'm not going to stick around
here for very long and i think the
reason for that was that i
always wanted to be in a mocha customer
facing role um
i couldn't see the tangibility of what i
was doing
i could not see the real world impact of
what i was doing
it was quite far removed from like you
know
seeing any impact of the work and so
it sort of just came quite naturally to
me and i think the way
my life progressed i still stuck it out
in tech for about four years
uh but i think the way my life
progressed and um the fact that
um i became a mother soon you know um
at the end of these four years it sort
of pushed me
into a um sort of a maternity break
and it gave me time to sort of think
about what it was that i really wanted
to do
and um and then when it came time to go
back to work i just said well you know
what
tech was not exciting enough to leave my
kids behind so i need to find something
else and
it just happened that i found my passion
in fruit
in food did you
ever think of starting a food business
when you were growing up when you were
studying was this ever a dream of yours
not at all not one percent and that is
why i think like
life throws you curveballs that you just
do not expect
i i'll tell you michael like i never
entered my
house kitchen till i was 25 years old
until i was sort of forced to fend for
myself i
really i there was i think there was a
certain sense of
non-achievement attached with cooking
when i was growing up especially
um for women in india so i always
thought well
i'm more than this i i don't have to be
in the kitchen like the women of my
generation or like the women
of previous generations and and i was in
some ways trying to i think come away
from it
but it was only when i sort of
culturally moved away from my home
country and i moved into
a new land of you know
um of being in england with my family i
realized that
food was really the strong almost like
the umbilical
cord that was holding me back to my
culture to my roots
and that is where i found my calling um
and and i just went
you know into the deep end so walk me
through
those first few weeks or months you're
200 pounds in savings i believe and
you're saying i'm gonna start
something new i'm gonna start cheeky
food right and
what is happening there what is how do
you even come up with an idea how do you
decide on the theme how do you
you know get the right people to to make
the recipes how does how do you actually
build the food business from that
ah so okay i'll tell you this is a this
is how the food business started
um my husband and i we were having
dinner one night kids were in bed and
um we just happened to have a condiment
just we that we had got off um the
supermarket here in england
and we just ate and we said well this is
quite this is not what
indian condiments are supposed to taste
like and and i was moaning about it and
my husband in this typical manner he
said well
instead of moaning why don't you do
something about it and i said that's it
that's right i'm going to start an
indian condiment food business
and and i'm going to show the people of
england what really indian condiments
are about
um and so um the interesting part about
coming up with the recipes
the next one week were absolute
whirlwind
i had two young kids i was sort of like
looking after them full time but
also trying to work out in my head what
were the recipes
that we really wanted to launch and the
interesting bit is uh
like most traditional cultures our
recipes are not written down
they are just passed verbally from
generation to generation so here i was
on the phone with my mom and my
mum-in-law
and saying well you know that mango
pickle that you made
like how how do i make it exactly again
and they were telling me over phone oh
well you add a pinch of salt right
now how do we convert that pinch of salt
into a proper tangible recipe that i can
commercially create and sort of
replicate uh you know production after
production
so um there was a lot of back and forth
there were a lot of recipes that went
wrong
um and this was sort of my post 8 pm
uh kitchen table project because i would
put the kids to bed
and then i would come into my kitchen
and i would start my
uh you know my time with my cheeky
recipes
and we we just sort of looked at what we
had available
what we enjoyed eating and i think one
of the things that really
helped me in selection of the recipes
was being a busy mom
in london i i sort of knew what worked
for families
so you know i didn't want anything too
complicated i wanted something that
would appeal to people living in london
having busy lives and could just chuck
on their food and add
tons of goodness and flavor to their
everyday meals and that's really just
how it went
and so i i can assume that your family
were your first customers they were
really the guinea pigs for a lot of
these recipes right
yes as they always are yeah my my family
and my friends were the guinea pigs
and it so happened that uh you know
while i was at this time um
it was uh coming up to christmas and um
there are a lot of christmas markets and
christmas pairs around here so i just
booked a table for like 10 pounds at the
local christmas market
got some jars i i knew enough about
uh you know uh design that i could um
create my own logos we printed them we
cut them out with like
literally going back scissors and um and
some
you know a4 sheets we cut out the labels
we stuck them on with glue
um and that's just how we launched it
and that was
um sort of putting 200 pounds in
thinking that's it
let's see if this works it sold out on
the first day
and um and the rest as they say is was
just like organically one step at a time
and so one step at a time and as you're
scaling your business and you're
growing and you're getting validation
from people
how do you strategically go about it do
you have this you know grand vision of
where you're gonna take this endeavor or
is it really day by day you're just
saying what happens and what do you feel
like doing
how do you i would say when i started
the business
so uh when i started the business my
grand vision was
really retail i wanted to see more and
more of my cheeky jars
in the biggest supermarkets in the uk
but i think one of the hardest learnings
as um i think when when you're an
engineer you sort of
like to work to a plan and it's almost
that if the numbers behave
you can stick to the plan but i think
one of the hardest things
as a food entrepreneur was that
um people's palettes change people's
preferences change
the food business the industry changes
and so you have to be quite
nimble-footed
in terms of being able to adapt to that
so what we found is actually that
strategically we've come away from that
vision of retail
and we found that more and more of our
products appeal to food manufacturers
to hospitality to restaurants to food
service
and and so we've just basically adapted
our strategy to grow
as a premium um condiment business
serving to these clients more b2b rather
than to c
interesting and so when you're deciding
on your
on your steps and you know i obviously
know very very little about
food strategies i know i'm thinking you
know as an entrepreneur
when i'll choose whatever type of
business i want to run i'm going to have
a bunch of different models of business
models revenue models partnership models
that i can just read a bunch of books
and say okay well this one makes the
most sense for my business i'll go and
try with this one
where do you get the inspiration from
yourself as you're entering
a world that you just don't know about
yeah it's uh um
i i don't i don't know where you know
what like i think it's
um it's it's not as
i in my head i don't keep it as
complicated as that
i just really take one day at a time
i have like about like a three month a
four month vision for the business
every four months we stop we take stock
of what's happened
we see where we have to go and i think
that kind of nimble
uh you know nimble strategy has really
helped us adapt during especially during
covert where
the best of strategies could have failed
you because nobody was prepared for what
was coming
and so the fact that our business was
quite lean in its structure
and that we had always sort of you know
we
were always quite light in um in our
step and light in our head
and we just thought well we will just
see does this stick
for four months we give it three or four
months does it stick
it does that's good we continue it
doesn't well we change strategy so
that's just how we've adapted so i i
don't even know if that's the best
business strategy to follow but it works
for us
no no it sounds great and so tell me a
little bit about cheeky food where you
are today
just for context of this of this great
endeavor
what is happening with chiki food today
so cheeky food we still uh operate in
the retail range but
a lot of our customers retail customers
uh
took the hit during covet and they had
to be shut down so our presence is
mostly online where we grew our business
um in 2020 um and uh
and what we have also done is um that we
have
strategic partnerships with a lot of the
leading manufacturers
and uh hospitality um customers
in the uk who use our products on their
recipes
and the way we develop these
relationships is basically
um we we become their arm of npd
for condiments we do the npd we create
them the recipes that they then take
back to their menus
and that is how we've really expanded
into some of the leading names
in uk hospitality wow and so
when you're and how long have you been
have this has been going on
since you started cheeky in its current
form six years
six years and so over these these past
six years what are some things that
really you know
maybe took you by surprise or inspired
you about about this endeavor
obviously i'm sure that there's a lot of
things that you know in that you've
discovered about yourself
that and and your passions that i'm
going to get to in a second but but from
a business perspective
what are some things that really took
you by surprise you said wow i
i really didn't expect it to go this way
or i didn't expect this
is how things operate in this world
um i'll tell you one of the uh one of
the examples that i've still not been
able to get out of my head so you know
when you go into a supermarket and you
see these um sales for example
uh like buy three get fourth free
i just thought that was a sale by the
supermarket i had no idea that it was
the brand behind that product
uh that was actually funding that sale
so
that's like yeah but like interesting so
when you see all these penny sales it's
actually not really the
um the retailer who's taking the hit of
it it's the brand
so one of the things that i absolutely
didn't expect in the food business
was how heavy the marketing is and
just absolutely right from day one you
have to go
big bang on the marketing marketing i
think
is one thing where i have really
struggled in the business and
maybe which is why that organically it
has appealed
to me to be more b2b rather than b2c
because i just find um
i just find that kind of spend on
marketing really hard
uh you know coming from an indian
background i'm just like oh
that's like money wasted like you know
i'd rather make more jars out of it
i think it's also more of an engineering
mindset yeah i i
yeah actually that's a good point that
probably is a good point because
um i think marketing has been my uh big
pain
um for the business and i absolutely
underestimated and i still
underestimate just how marketing
extensive
any consumer facing product based
business can be
right and so now a little bit more about
your journey
you start off engineer mathematician
tech food entrepreneur how have you
grew you know personally internally you
know one of the
categories you know mindfulness uh
business um
do you know what michael i think one of
the things that the business has really
um really given me
is that i do not have a boss and that
can be
scary but absolutely
um you know it can let you expand your
wings
in ways that you cannot imagine it can
it can be both your curse but also your
boom
and i think it has worked very well for
me that there is no
safety net and so every decision that
you take in a business so
it's sort of like comes down to are you
a mindful person are you really aware of
the decisions why you're taking it
so often in a hierarchical job structure
we tend to say well i'm taking this
decision because
it's it's a hierarchical decision it's
been sort of
forced upon me so i'm just doing this
you know but when you're sort of your
own boss
you really have to question why you take
the decisions that you take
and i think that is what the business i
think i did have a streak like that
which is why i was drawn towards
entrepreneurship
but um i do definitely think that
running a business for six years
you can often take a step back and think
am i really doing this
because it satisfies some part of my ego
is it because
i like my name out there is that or is
that
really because i really want to
satisfy the why of why i started this
business was to bring a great quality
product to people so so
the business at every decision every
point even
the decision to have this podcast
together with you
it's a little bit like you know you can
introspect and you can think
am i doing this because i just want to
put my name out there or do i really
have something interesting to say
that can be helpful and and and i
tend to take those decisions sort of
quite seriously and i like to
interrogate myself
why i take the decisions that i take and
that's really helped me
evolve as a person which i don't think i
could have done if i was working for
someone else
i think that is perhaps the most
inspiring thing i have gained from
this conversation and i've gained a lot
of insights in this conversation but
but the this idea of interrogating
yourself and this
idea of consist consistently asking
yourself why are you doing what you're
doing
and having the the privilege of having
to do that
because anybody can do it even if you do
have a boss you can always ask yourself
why did i do this and not that
but the idea that you're forced to do it
as a practice
because otherwise it's not going to work
there's
i think that's that that's beautiful and
it's it's something that i
i strive to do both in the projects that
i do have a boss and i don't have a boss
and and i think it's just really really
cool
swadi i have a few more fun questions
for you if you're ready
yeah absolutely go on all right what is
your favorite subject in middle or high
school
oh um maths
okay one of your role models
is somebody that inspires you naval
ravikanth
he's actually in the tech world so yeah
okay
wonderful and three words that you would
use to describe yourself and why those
three words
uh i'd say i'm passionate i'm very
resilient
and very hard to um
[Music]
uh you're passionate resilient and very
hard working
and and the reason i say it is that
those three qualities just
define me at you know at the core of the
person that i am
i love it swati thank you so so much
this is really really great i appreciate
you taking the time to be here
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
michael
uh thank you for having me it was a
pleasure talking to you thank you very
much
[Music]